die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara
hallweg guten Abend und willkommen
Norbert Lehmann ist auch wieder dabei
für den Sport einen schön guten Abend
auch von mir das sind die
Nachrichtenthemen von heute
Urteil zur AFD Jugend der
Verfassungsschutz darf die junge
Alternative als gesichert extremistisch
einstufen Trauer und Wut in der Türkei
und Syrien ein Jahr nach dem
katastrophalen Beben fühlen sich viele
Überlebende im Stich
gelassen nach der Krebsdiagnose von King
Charles Großbritannien hofft und bankt
und diskutiert das Thema Krebs sehr
offen das Verwaltungsgericht Köln hat es
jetzt bestätigt der Verfassungsschutz
darf die Jugendorganisation der AFD als
gesichert rechtsextremistisch einstufen
und beobachten damit wies das Gericht
einen Eilantrag der AFD und der jungen
alternative zurück zu Begründung hieß es
unter anderem der Ausschluss ethnisch
fremder wie in die junge alternative
verfolge verstoße gegen die
Menschenwürde SAR te
berichtet die junge Alternative für
Deutschland die Jugendorganisation der
AFD so zeigt sie sich auf ihrem eigenen
YouTube-Kanal und ebenfalls öffentlich
äußert sich auch ihr Vorsitzender hier
im April vergangenen Jahres
dieteierung hier ein
Bevölkerungsaustausch und Sie werden
nicht ruhen bis jeder Winkel unseres
Landes und jedes friedliche Dorf mit
illegal Migranten vollgestofft ist
außerdem bezeichnet die junge
alternative Einwanderer allgemein als
Schmarotzer und kriminell und missachte
dadurch die Menschenwürde entschied nun
das Verwaltungsgericht Köln die
umfangreiche Entscheidung des
Verwaltungsgerichts Köln fällt
außerordentlich eindeutig aus das
Verwaltungsgericht stellt fest dass die
junge Alternative einen ethnisch
homogenen Volksbegriff vertritt dass sie
gegen die Demokratie agitiert und dass
sie
ausländerfeindlich ist und den Islam
verächtlich macht das klingt fast schon
so wie bei der NPD deshalb darf die
junge alternative vom Verfassungsschutz
mit allen nachrichtendienstlichen
Mitteln wie fauluten Telefonüberwachung
observation beobachtet werden bestätigte
das Verwaltungsgericht Köln eine
Entscheidung die die
bundesinnenministerin begrüßt wir
schützen unsere Demokratie mit allen
rechtsstaatlichen Mitteln und dass wir
rechtsstaatliche Mittel anwenden hat das
Gerichtsurteil heute sehr stark
bestätigt weder die AFD noch der
Verfassungsschutz waren heute zu einer
Stellungnahme bereit gegen die
Entscheidung kann die junge alternative
noch Beschwerde
einlegen heute zum Safer Internet Day
präsentiert die Bildungsstätte Anne
Frank eine neue Studie danach spielen
sozial Medien eine weit unterschätzte
Rolle bei der Verbreitung von
Antisemitismus und
Rechtsextremismus besonders tiktok trage
zur Radikalisierung junger Menschen bei
keine soziale Plattform wächst derzeit
so rasant wie tiktok ein Teenager in
Deutschland verbringt dort
durchschnittlich 95 Minuten pro Tag wie
Schulen reagieren zeigt Laura
zdober Medienerziehung am
frauenlobgymnasium in Mainz die neunte
Klasse spricht über tiktok und
rechtsextreme
etwa musiklips mit vökischnationalem
Text oder Videos wie dieses das erstmal
wie ein harmloses waldvideo wirkt aber
in Wirklichkeit für eine rechtsextreme
Jugendorganisation wirbt man muss geübt
sein um solche Inhalte als problematisch
zu erkennen ich denke mit der Zeit wenn
man dem Thema viel ausgesetzt ist merkt
man sich schon welcher Sound die vereint
wenn man in die Kommentare schaut steht
da dann meistens achtung das stimmt
nicht tiktok ist die Plattform für
Kinder und Jugendliche und darum sind
hier auch viele rechtsextreme unterwegs
um gezielt Nachwuchs zu rekrutieren
gerade junge Menschen sind politisch
noch beeinflussbar allerdings auf tiktok
findet oft nur der Erstkontakt statt und
das bei Interesse bei der Möglichkeit
der Identifikation man dann in die
ebenfalls ja gebotenen weiteren Kanäle
hineingeht und dort dann die eigentliche
Radikalisierung stattfindet um das zu
verhindern müssen Kinder einen
kritischen Umgang mit tiktok lernen dazu
gehört auch Rechtsextreme Codes zu
erkennen bestimmte Hashtags z.B oder
typische Farbkombinationen etwa
schwarzweiß rot die Farben der
Reichsflagge das steht und fällt
natürlich damit dass man den Kindern da
die Kinder auch an der Hand nimmt und
Ihnen erklärt wie so eine subtile
Symbolik auch aussieht tiktok ein
Wohlfühlort für Kinder aber auch ein Ort
rechtsextremer
Propaganda eigentlich wollte die EU am
Freitag ein lieferkettengesetz auf den
Weg bringen nach langen Verhandlungen
jetzt steht fest dass Deutschland nicht
zustimmen wird grund sei der Widerstand
der FDP sagte Arbeitsminister Heil von
der SPD er warf ihr eine ideologisch
motivierte Blockade vor sie habe seine
Kompromissvorschläge endgültig abgelehnt
das Gesetz würde größere Unternehmen in
der EU verpflichten
Menschenrechtsstandards in der
Produktion und bei Lieferanten zu
gewährleisten die FD hält es für zu
bürokratisch die EU-Kommission macht
Tempo beim Einsparen von Treibhausgasen
denn viele Mitgliedstaaten hängen weit
hinter den eu-zielen her bislang galt
der Richtwert dass bis 2030 die CO2
Emissionen um 55% im Vergleich zu 1990
gesenkt werden sollen bis 2050 soll die
EU klimaneutral werden das neue
Zwischenziel für 2040 lautet jetzt 90%
weniger Emissionen als
1990 ein entsprechender
Gesetzesvorschlag müsste nach den
Europawahlen von der nächsten
EU-Kommission vorgelegt
werden genau ein Jahr ist es her dass in
der Türkei die Erde bebte und in der
Region rund 60.000 Menschen in den
todriss die Erdstöße trafen vor allem
den Südosten der Türkei besonders die
Provinzen hattai und Karaman Maras sie
erschütterten auch den Norden Syriens
allein in der Türkei wurden zetausende
Häuser zerstört Präsident erdogan hatte
schnelle umfassende Hilfe versprochen
doch noch immer leben 100tausende
Menschen in Notunterkünften
über Trauer und Wut am Jahrestag der
Katastrophe Görg
Brase sie schreien ihre Wut hinaus
fordern den Rücktritt des
Gesundheitsministers und des
provinzbürgermeisters die
Gedenkveranstaltung am frühen Morgen in
antakia wird zum Protest man habe sie
nach dem Beben im Stich gelassen so
es hat geregnet es war kalt von
überallen kamen Schreie und es ist jetzt
ein Jahr lang her und antakia ist immer
noch nicht aufgebaut wir leben immer
noch in Containern wir leben immer noch
in Zelten die Regierung streitet ab dass
es solche zeltunterkünfte noch gibt doch
diese Bilder zeigen das
Gegenteil wenn wir das Zelt nicht hätten
was würden wir dann tun ich war Mieter
das Haus ist eingestürzt wir mussten uns
so ein Zelt bauen keine Ahnung wie es
weitergehen soll
ent versprechen alles innerhalb eines
Jahres wieder aufzubauen war heute keine
Rede mehr stattdessen
Eigenlob es gibt nur wenige Länder und
Gesellschaften die angesichts einer
solchen Katastrophe so standhaft bleiben
können wie wir doch nicht nationalen
Stolz empfinden die meisten Betroffenen
hier in hatai sondern Schmerz über den
erlittenen
Verlust Überlebende forderten auch heute
wieder Gerechtigkeit sie wollen dass die
Verantwortlichen für Baumängel die zum
Einsturz vieler Gebäude führten bestraft
werden baunternehmer aber auch
Mitarbeiter der Genehmigungsbehörden
dass diese jedoch verurteilt werden das
zeigen die Erfahrungen aus dem letzten
großen Beben
1999 ist allerdings kaum zu erwarten
daran aber dachten heute wohl nur die
wenigsten heute war der Tag an dem sie
ihre Toten betrauern
wollten US-Präsident Trump und seinen
Problemen mit der Justiz ein
Berufungsgericht in Washington hat jetzt
klargestellt dass er Verhandlungen in
seiner Amtszeit strafrechtlich verfolgt
werden kann konkret geht es um eine
Anklage wegen versuchten Wahlbetrugs im
Zusammenhang mit dem Sturm auf das
Kapitol am Ende wird der Oberste
Gerichtshof grundsätzlich entscheiden
müssen inwi weit US-Präsidenten
Immunität in Anspruch nehmen können
fragen wir Claudia Bates in Washington
was bedeutet das für Trump und seine
geplante
Präsidentschaftskandidatur ja Trump
wollte das Verfahren wegen Wahlbetrugs
verhindern und das ist ihm erstmal nicht
gelungen seine Anwälte hatten
argumentiert dass er gar nicht
strafrechtlich verfolgt werden könnte
weil er als Präsident Immunität genieße
nun hat also das Gericht darüber
geurteilt ob ein Präsident im Amt quasi
alles darf unter dem Schutz der
Immunität und sagt nein auch ein
Präsident steht nicht über dem Gesetz
die GEW altenteilung würde nicht mehr
funktionieren wenn der Präsident
jenseits der Reichweite des Parlaments
und der Justiz wäre ein Präsident könne
keine Verbrechen begehen um die
grundlegendste Kontrolle in der
Demokratie die Wahlen eben auszuhebeln
aber eines ist Trump schon gelungen er
konnte den Prozess wegen Wahlbetrugs er
zwar nicht verhindern aber hinauszögern
und letztlich hofft er dass bis zur Wahl
im November das Verfahren noch nicht
abgeschlossen ist und er dann
gegebenenfalls als Präsident das
Justizministerium anweisen könnte das
Verfahren einzustellen vielen Dank für
diese Erklärung aus Washington Claudia
Bates war
das in der Ukraine hat das Parlament das
Kriegsrecht und die Mobilisierung
verlängert mit großer Mehrheit doch die
große Unterstützung für die Regierung
scheint zu Bröckel angesichts der
schwierigen Lage an der Front plant
Präsident selenskiki offenbar den
Oberbefehlshaber der Truppen salusni zu
entlassen der gilt aber als populär
Katrin Eigendorf
berichtet der Präsident zu Besuch in
einem Trainingszentrum der Armee seitdem
sich Gerüchte mehren dass volodimir
selenski den beliebten Oberbefehlshaber
der Streitkräfte Valeri salusni absetzen
will herrscht Verunsicherung vor allen
bei den
Soldaten ein Machtkampf droht denn
Valeri salusni will bleiben und das Land
weiterführen im Krieg gegen Russland in
Kiev treffe ich
den Bürgermeister der Stadt er warnt vor
einer weiteren
Eskalation in das Land was befindet sich
in Krieg das ist eine riesige große
fehle für jede Politiker gibt keinen
Sinn einen Wettkampf zu machen zum eine
Position zu kämpfen weil heute die Frage
steht ganz scharf wirdine Überlebende
Krieg oder nicht wirdine
exist in seinem Büro hängt ein Foto von
salni der Bürgermeister macht aus seiner
Sympathie keinen he er sehr beliebt sehr
sehr beliebt Menschen bei
bevolkung und er Kommand von neu
Generation denke ich mal solche Figuren
zu wechseln das ist ein
F dass die Ukrainer auf europäische
Unterstützung weitersetzen können
Versicherte heute der EU chefdipomat jor
bei seinem Besuch in
Kiev Kräfte der Ukraine werden Training
erhalten um das zu erreichen was
schwieriger ist als man annimmt die
Kontrolle über ihr Territorium wieder zu
erlangen das Leben
wiederherzustellen ein Moment der
Hoffnung in einem Land das nach Z Jahren
Krieg keine Aussicht auf Frieden
sieht vitalie Klitschkos Einschätzung
zur Lage in der Ukraine aber auch zur
Anteilnahme in Deutschland erfahren Sie
im kompletten auslandsjournal Interview
sehen jederzeit in der ZDF Mediathek
unter
zdf.de auf deutschen Straßen hakt es
wieder häufiger der ADAC registrierte
2023 deutlich mehr Stau und stockenden
Verkehr als im Jahr zuvor insgesamt
hingen Autofahrer
427 000 Stunden fest das sind knapp 30%
mehr als
2022 einen Grund sieht der ADAC darin
dass wieder mehr Menschen zu ihrem
Arbeitsplatz fahren das Niveau der
vorcoronazeit ist allerdings noch nicht
erreicht seit Sonntag gibt es im
US-Bundesstaat Kalifornien heftige
Unwetter mindestens drei Menschen sind
dabei ums Leben gekommen starker Regen
löste Erdrutsche aus überflutete Straßen
und legte die Energieversorgung lahm
mehr als 700000 Menschen waren zeitweise
ohne Strom im Verlauf des Tages sollen
die Niederschläge nachlassen die von
Überschwemmungen bleibe aber weiterhin
hoch aus der ganzen Welt kommen
Genesungswünsche Prince harry ist aus
den USA angereist King Charles ist an
Krebs erkrankt das hat der Buckingham
Palace gestern Abend mitgeteilt seine
Majestät wolle damit Spekulationen
vermeiden und habe die Hoffnung dass
dies zum Verständnis für all diejenigen
auf der ganzen Welt beiträgt die von
Krebs betroffen sind aus London Wolf
Christian
Ulrich König charz heute Abend zur
Erholung nach Schloss Sandringham die
ersten Bilder seit bekanntwererden
seiner Krebsdiagnose in Großbritannien
heute große
Anteilnahme ich wünsche ihm alles Gute
das ist doch traurig dass unser König
diese Krankheit
hat die Familie hat einiges durchgemacht
und jetzt das ein weiterer
Schlag am Nachmittag landete sogar Prinz
Harry in London die Krankheit lässt
frühere familiäre Streitigkeiten in den
Hintergrund treten
bei allen Zerwürfnissen der König hat
immer gesagt dass er seine Söhne liebt
und Harry hat immer gesagt dass er
seinen Vater liebt und Charles wird sehr
froh sein seinen Sohn heute zu
sehen gerade erst hat der König das
Krankenhaus nach einer
prostatabehandlung in guter Stimmung
verlassen da entdecken die Ärzte den
Krebs und das im Jahr 2 ein Regentschaft
auf die er jahrzehntelang hingearbeitet
hatte es ist doch traurig dass es den
König so schnell nach seiner Krönung
erwischt hat der König doch kein
Lückenfüller zu sein sondern er füllt
sein Amt richtig
aus trotz der Krebsbehandlung führre
Charles die Amtsgeschäfte weiter nur die
öffentlichen Termine fielen aus so der
Palast der Krebs sei frühzeitig erkannt
verriet der
Premierminister er wird sehr frustriert
sein dass seine Pläne seine Reisen
verschoben sind er ist ein
Workoholic dass der Palast überhaupt so
offen über Charles Gesundheitszustand
spricht ist neu durch Transparenz auch
Aufmerksamkeit zu schaffen für
Gesundheitsvorsorge selbst in
persönlicher Krise ein Dienst am
Volk tja gar nicht so
schlecht jetzt DFB Pokal da stehen die
letzten beiden Viertelfinalspiel an ja
heute abend Leverkusen gegen Stuttgart
ein echtes Topspiel aber auch morgen
dürfte es so richtig spannend werden
denn dann muss Gladbach beim
Drittligisten seibrücken antreten und
der hat ja schon die Bayern und
Frankfurt aus dem Pokal
geworfen Coach Rüdiger Ziel stimmt sein
Team ein auf die dritte exakte Analyse
eines Bundesligisten soll morgen die
dritte Pokalsensation folgen wir haben
eine super Moral wir haben super
Teamgeist und werden alles dran setzen
dass wir das auch noch mal schaffen
können die Bayern durch das Tor von
Marcel Gaus aus dem Pokal geworfen
danach die Frankfurter Eintracht besiegt
Erinnerungen an diese Höhepunkte
schwingen auch im Training immer mit als
Motivation ich nutze auch
tikt mir werden jetzt die letzten Tage
nur noch Videos von sbrücken angezeigt
wie gausi da das Tor schießt also ja du
wirst eben halt schon oft dran erinnert
und das nimmt man natürlich mit ins
Spiel hoffentlich spielt auch der etwas
ledierte und im Moment noch abgedeckte
Rasen mit
inarbrücken ja und das Spiel morgen
Abend live bei uns im ZDF zu sehen ab
20:15 Uhr zur Fußball buundesliga der
Frauen da hat Bayern München die
Tabellenführung übernommen durch den
souveränen 140 Heimsieg gestern Abend
gegen
Freiburg der Auftritt der Münchnerinnen
hatte auch etwas von einer Trotzreaktion
nach dem Aus in der vergene Woche die
Gastgeberinnen dominierten dieses Spiel
in der Minute bereits das 1 durch Linda
sembrand und Lea Schüller überzeugt in
ihrem 200 Bundesligaspiel das 2:0 die
eingewechselte Linda dmann erhöhte nach
der Pause auf 3:0 damit nicht genug
gegen zu harmlos agierende
Freiburgerinnen traf Katharina
naschenweng zum
4:0 Südkorea mit
Trainer Cup verpasst das Team verlor am
Abend das Halbfinale gegen Jordanien
hier das Z Z durch durch Musa altamari
in der 66 spielminute zum 2:0 Endstand
seit 64 Jahren wartet Südkorea nun schon
auf den Gewinn des
asiencups kein Wintermärchen für
Südkorea aber wir hatten ja unser
Sommermärchen mit cliny 2006 auch ohne
Titel W uns ewig dran erinnern können in
Teilen nordrheinwestfahens gibt's morgen
gbigen Dauerregen womit Sonne oder
Schnee zu rechnen ist erklärt gleich
Katja hornifer Dunja Hayali begrüß sie
um vi uh im heute journal und wir sind
morgen wieder da einen schönen Abend
noch auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen guten Abend dieses Regenband
markiert die Grenze zwischen kühlerer
Luft im Norden und milderer Luft im
Süden es setzt jetzt etwa ab Mitternacht
ergiebiger Dauerregen in
nordrinwestfalen ein bis Freitag früh
können hier ördlich 60 bis 80 l Regen
pro Quadratmeter zusammenkommen heute
Nacht wird es auch einen starken bis
stürmischen Wind in der Nordhälfte geben
und unter den Regenwolken bleibt's recht
mild da sinken die Werte auf 9 bis 7° im
Norden sind es so 6 bis 1 im Süden 6 bis
0° und morgen zieht dieses Regen und
schneefallgebiet langsam weiter südwärts
dann kann es auch in den östlichen
Mittelgebirgen für Schnee reichten am
Alpenrand bleibt's noch am längsten
freundlich und hinter dem Regenband
werden sie auch in Norddeutschland
häufiger die Sonne zu Gesicht bekommen
von Norden wird's kälter so liegen
morgen Abend die Temperaturen hier im
Nordosten bei 0 bis 4° in der
Südwesthälfte bleibt es dagegen bei 7
bis 11° noch milder am Donnerstag kommt
schon gleich der nächste Regen und
Schnee von Westen heran und in der Nacht
zu Freitag und Freitag früh müssen sie
sich in mecklenburg- vorpom und
Schleswig-Holstein auf Schneefall
einstellen machen sie sich auf glatte
Straßen gefasst guten Abend